dr. strange is directed by scott
derrickson and stars Benedict
Cumberbatch as Stephen strange a very
successful but arrogant doctor who after
a debilitating car accident can no
longer use his hands this is life now
you know that really low and suck and
when Western medicine fails him he turns
to Eastern medicine and discovers this
Monastery of sorts in which he learns
about magic sorcery and many different
dimensions he never knew existed as well
as a mystical war that is raging and he
tries to find his place in between these
two warring things it's my best way to
describe this movie I got to say I got
to give the writers of this movie major
props because Marvel has once again
introduced a very strange and obscure
comic book character into their MCU and
made it work I thought Thor and Asgard
was going to be hard I thought ant-man
was going to be weird one of the reasons
this character works so well is because
of Benedict Cumberbatch in fact it is
the biggest reason he really gives a lot
to this role he has the perfect level of
arrogance comedy wit and confusion
especially confusion but what I loved
about his character was how passionate
he was about bettering himself he's
someone who takes his intellect very
seriously arrogantly so but at the same
time he's also someone who just wants to
learn everything he can to get better at
whatever he wants to do it's one of the
reasons why his character was such a
successful physician and it's one of the
reasons he becomes such a successful
sorcerer because he wants to better
himself in every way he can and so that
aspect of the character I really latched
on to and really appreciate it what
really blew me away in this movie were
the visuals this was a very remarkable
3d experience I do actually recommend
that you see it in 3d normally that's
not something that I focus on but the 3d
definitely added something to these city
bending world moving sequences that
really made my jaw drop the action
sequences in this film are fantastic
save for one thing I don't necessarily
think Scott Derrickson handled some of
the hand-to-hand combat sequences as
effectively as he could have it's not
shakey
there was just a level of intensity
missing from the more simple action
sequences that were given to the
incredible visual effects heavy
sequences which by the way I say visual
effects heavy but I never really looked
at something I was like man that's such
a computer image I don't buy any of this
for a second these are class-a visual
effects some of the best I've ever seen
and yes it is going to draw comparisons
to Inception in the Matrix that's
inevitable but Doctor Strange as a comic
has been around for a while and this
aspect of that world has been in those
comics for a while but it's clearly
drawing inspiration from inception
people jumping on walls and the gravity
defying elements it's just that there's
a lot more of it in this film I love Chi
Weddell II Joe for as Mordo he was a lot
of fun Tilda Swinton was very good as
the ancient one I thought she was great
in the movie it would have been nice to
see that character portrayed by someone
who was actually the ethnicity of the
character in the comic but I'm not gonna
sit here and complain about it because
she was really good in the movie and my
boy Mads Mikkelsen oh my god I love him
he was so good in this movie his
character could have been given a little
more though I would have appreciated a
little more depth behind him another
thing I really appreciated about this
movie is that it does feel very
different from the other films in the
MCU certain elements of the third act
it's extremely different from the way
most of these big superhero extravaganza
visual effects beam in the sky people
blow up everything movies now I love
superheroes I love comic books I love
comic book movies but it was just nice
to see one that fits into the world that
has the similar warm color tones and
tongue-in-cheek humor and visual effects
and amazing action sequences but it was
nice to see one that genuinely felt of
its own world as for negatives I feel
that the first act is a little bit
clunky and setting up the character and
getting to the place where he eventually
meets the ancient one the second she
touches his forehead from that moment on
I was just I was in I was locked into
the movie it was a really fun ride but
getting to that felt a little blocky
just a little bit the pacing could have
been a lot better there's some humor
also that doesn't always work I would
say it's about 70/30 for me in regards
to humor and jokes that hit and it does
kind of rush through some of his
training aspects
and you feel like there should be a
little bit more there are comparisons to
be made to Batman Begins because Bruce
Wayne in that movie travels to this
faraway land and learns all these
mystical magical things and in this one
it's a lot more literal in regards to
the magic but in Batman Begins it was
just pasted better and you felt that
world building and this movie it kind of
wants to get to dr. strange getting his
red cape the levitation cloak and
everything being really cool and awesome
and it's cool to see everything happen
and you're excited that it's getting to
that point but I do feel like his
training was rushed just a little bit
the movie also suffers from a lot of
exposition now that's one of the biggest
flaws I would say of this movie is the
need to explain so much to us because
it's such a weird different world from
the other MCU films that there are many
scenes in which our hero is standing
there listening to people explaining
things to him and we're going to need
some of that and I wouldn't say that it
wasn't interesting I would say that it
was mostly always fun and compelling to
watch and learn about this world it just
does get really bogged down in
exposition sometimes as for visual
effects in this movie everything was
mind-blowing ly great except for one
visual effects character that I was just
kind of like that's a cartoon I don't
believe that that's real also I really
liked Rachel McAdams in this movie she
plays the love interest of sorts of
Stephen strange they have some
off-and-on
together but I liked how he had to keep
going back to her at certain points for
help it added a lot of humor to the
movie that mostly worked very well in
the end Doctor Strange has incredible
visual effects a very cool hero a very
fun backstory that does get bogged down
in a lot of exposition mostly working
humor and a character that I can't wait
to see more of it's not one of the best
in the MCU I wouldn't say it's more than
worst it's not as good as civil war or
Deadpool this year but I had a lot of
fun with this movie and I love Benedict
Cumberbatch as this character and I'm
excited to see him and other films I'm
gonna give Doctor Strange a B+ guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I look forward to hearing about what you
guys thought of Doctor Strange guys
thank you once again and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you